so um we i want to start the show today
with
something we haven't done in a long time
today
is game show day it is time to play a
brand new game
the game is called fake or festival
hit it guys it's a tour through fact
fiction welcome to
fake or festival welcome back to another
edition of fake or festival the game
today
is is it a fake or as a festival playing
today our contestant barry corder from
chattanooga tennessee introduce us to
you
barry corder hey everybody i'm excited
to play
what am i playing for oh it's very very
exciting it's tickets to
bonnaroo 2020. you can win a pair of
tickets to bonnaroo 2020
all for winning fake or festival i'm
going to give you a name of a festival
you tell me if it is a fake
or a festival are you ready to play
barry from chattanooga
let me stretch i'm ready i'm ready let's
go first time caller long time listener
first time long time here we go berry
corner plays fake or festival
head in the clouds head in the clouds is
it a fake festival or a real festival
real head in the clouds is a fake
festival i'm sorry
sorry you're over one number two number
two
rolling loud rolling loud fake festival
or
real festival fake
fake festival the actual answer is real
festival
rolling loud let me introduce you to
loud festival it's in miami
the lineup this year asap rocky post
malone travis scott
and of course the the little uzi little
babies baby oozies and oozy babies big
big party down in miami you ready for
number three very quarter
i'm gonna have to say no first right
answer you've given so far
i know somebody missed two great
opportunities first one
that was a great idea and the second was
a horrible name that's right
forbidden kingdom forbidden kingdom
oh my gosh the forbidden kingdom
festival
real forbidden kingdom festival is a
real festival
it is all base and dubstep uh it is
june 11th and 12th and again central
florida and orlando the
vans you can see there are dream takers
hero bust
hi i'm ghost and dr p
funt case all right all right you got
you're on the board barry you're on the
board
number i win tickets to that festival we
could probably afford those
uh number four skitty diddy
skitty diddy the skitty diddy music
festival music
festival skitty diddy fake that is a
fake festival you
are tied up two and two back in the game
back in the game we go to number five
tree fort the tree fort music festival
real now are you google searching now
are you google searching because that is
a real festival you're exactly right
in downtown boise idaho uh comes
tree fort music festival the tree fort
music lineup
japanese breakfast lake street dive uh
built to spill lark and po our buddies
from
um do maktar it's a pretty good lineup
tennis is gonna be there it's a pretty
good tennis from uh from nashville
tennessee so a pretty good lineup there
for
the tree fort music festival and finally
finally barry's on
the board to seal the deal and win these
bonnaroo 2020 tickets
the final fake festival the rio festival
is
destination dubstep destination dubstep
i'm gonna say fake it is a fake festival
big finish four and two wow
congratulations you're the big winner
today on fake
or festival
you did well buddy